so Paul why is persistence important and
how how many prototypes can you expect
to make if you're actually building out
an app from scratch a lot way more than
you think you should or than you think
is at all reasonable your trashcan
should be full by the end of the week
every single week and I'm you know I'm
not talking about full-blown interactive
JavaScript prototypes that's gonna take
a lot longer I'm talking about sketched
prototypes when you start you want to
focus on iterating quickly and the
cheapest possible medium and often that
can be crayons right you go out to it
actually every time I go out to a
restaurant I ask for a kids menu and
crayons if I see them so that if I have
an idea or I want to jot something down
or whatever I have pen and paper there
and I can sketch it out right there are
a couple different iphone apps if you're
doing a noble development that lets you
turn sketches very quickly into kind of
mock interactive prototypes right but it
works perfectly fine just to sit there
and actually move the paper around to
create the impression of interactivity
right and interactive prototypes are
great because you can make them super
super super fast you can make them super
quickly right right sketching out 10
prototypes 10 full flows through your
abs should take you no more than an hour
or two then you take those prototypes
around 25 different people in your
office and walk them through each one
and now you have an amazing amount of
user testing data right going to be
invaluable as you start to move into
interactive prototypes or like click
through prototypes or fold JavaScript
interactive prototypes and as time goes
on you'll get faster at building these
prototypes into finding users to test
with exactly yeah as you go on you one
you'll get better at knowing which
interactions or how to how to represent
interactions in paper mm-hmm you'll get
better with your tools your interactive
click through tools you'll get if you
start coding better at javascript so
you'll get more better at talking to the
developers who are actually building the
prototype about which things matter to
speed that up and as you get better at
that of course you get faster and so you
can really tear through prototypes and
just throw them out at the end so one
thing that's really important to
remember about these paper prototypes
and interactive prototypes is that the
first times that you make them you're
going to look at them and you're going
to say this sucks
this is terrible this not at the right
solution and that's fine that's
absolutely perfect right your goal is
not to find the right solution the first
time your goal is to iterate lots and
lots and lots and lots and lots and lots
and lots and lots and lots and lots of
times and eventually find the best
solution right separate from that as a
developer as a designer as a prototype
for yourself you're going to look at
this and say this is not the best thing
that I could have made or your craft
will not be very good that's fine you're
gonna suck at this for a long time and
before you're good at it right that's
part of doing this and because you're
doing so many of these you're going to
get better really fast and so the best
thing that you can do is just keep going
just keep making prototypes keep
sketching keep making interactive
prototypes and you will get faster you
will get better it will get easier just
keep going